[Music]
or
or never changes
in 1776 this great nation accepted that
armed conflict was the only way to
preserve our rights to life liberty the
pursuit of happiness
if our founding fathers could only see
us now
for my auntie's of Italian Okinawa to
Anchorage we have fought and now the Red
Menace is that our doorstep democracy
itself is under threat of annihilation
that is why today July 4th 2076 300
years after our great nation began we
gathered together to honor the
completion a vault 76 this sprawling
underground shelter may have been
engineered by vault-tec but it was built
by you the good people of America so
that if the bombs do come if the end
does come our way of life will endure
but not everyone will be saved those
chosen to enter this fault must be our
best and our brightest for when a
fighting is stopped and the fallout has
settled
you must rebuild not just walls not just
buildings but hearts and minds and
ultimately America itself so as we stand
here today we pray that the world will
know peace but if that is not our
destiny if war must come we stand
together knowing but here involved 76
our future begins
[Music]
play the beta first on Xbox one
[Music]
you